Here are some cooking tips straight from SCP-5031’s
brand new cookbook, “Quantum Cooking With
the Murder Monster!”
Tip 1: Be sure to use all six of your arms
for ultimate cooking precision!
Kitchen knives are also no good - Be sure
to use your bladed tail for all cooking activities!
Tip 2: Cook to music!
My personal favorite is Jethro Tull, but ambient
mixes of calm morning forests will also do
for getting you into that perfect cooking
zone.
Tip 3: Pick only the best ingredients!
Cooked rotisserie chickens taste much better
than volleyballs, I’ve learned this from
experience.
Tip 4: The kitchen is a special place.
If someone enters your kitchen and refuses
to respect your rules, cut them to pieces
with your bladed tail and turn them into a
nice goulash.
They’ll be much better off that way!
Tip 5: More garlic powder is always a good
thing!
Quantum Cooking with the Murder Monster by
SCP-5031 is available at no good retailers.
Pre-order now!